لا مبروك لكم نجاح فيلم الباب الاخضر
وحدثنا عن الاسباب التي قادت الى هذا
النجاح
معكم جدا همم
مبسوط اكيد برده اني ردود الافعال الكبيره
اللي جاءت لي على باب الاخضر
والحمد لله
طب ما جاوبتني يا استاذ رؤوف قبل ما نروح
عند نادين ايش الاسباب التي نجاح وتحقيق
هذا النجاح
اكيد رقم واحد الاستاذ اسامه باشا همم
همم نص همم بالكامل همم من من تاليف
الاستاذ اسامه سيناريو وحوار وطبعا قصه
اكيد ده السر الاول في النجاح وبعد كده
الاجتهاد الحمد لله اللي همم اللي قام به
فريق العمل بالكامل واللي بشكر كل الناس
اللي ساعدوني في التجربه دي سواء وراء
الكاميرا او قدام الكاميرا بصراحه
الباب الاخضر اللي اعتمد على كتابه
سيناريو قبل 30 عاما عم نحكي عن الراحل
اسامه انور عكاشه هل كان اسهل اخراجيا
بالنسبه لكم ام هناك صعوبه بيفهم ما كان
يدور في راس الكاتب قبل 30 عاما
اكيد تجربه صعبه جدا على المستوى الاخراجي
بس في نفس الوقت
الاستاذ اسامه طريقه الكتابه عنده والسرد
حقيقي واضحه جدا طبعا الطلعه على كل النسخ
الاستاذ اسامه قام بتعديلها
وتظبيط حاجات مختلفه من وقت للثاني لان هو
كتب الفيلم على فترات مختلفه
وقام بتعديله اكثر من مره طبعا ده غير عشق
الكبير همم اللي فن الاستاذ اسامه
صغير باحب اعماله سواء وانا همم
بادرس اعماله سواء لما جيت كمان همم اعمل
باب الاخضر عملت عمليه بحث كبير للاستاذ
اسامه في همم في في افكار وفي الطرق اللي
دائما بيحب بيقدم بها شخصياته يعني كنت
عامل شبه دراسه كثيره